a cowardly ambush that is how the chief
justice of the Ohio Supreme Court is
describing the shooting of a fellow
judge in Steubenville judge Joseph
Brizzy was brizzy's rather when jr. was
shot near the courthouse yesterday
police say the gunman a convicted felon
nathaniel richmond was killed when the
judge and a probation officer returned
fire Richmond the father of Malik
Richmond a former high school football
player who was convicted of raping a 16
year old girl at a party in 2012
Jericka Duncan is outside the courthouse
in Steubenville Ohio with the latest on
this tariqa good morning the courthouse
remains closed today because of
yesterday's shooting now officials say
the suspect was waiting for the judge
who had just parked his car in a
reserved spot and was walking down this
side street when the gunman opened fire
and this was just cold-blooded attempted
murder
a judge Jefferson County Sheriff Fred
Abdullah says he has no doubt the
shooting of Judge Joseph brizzy's was an
ambush it's frustrating when I see this
man get right up on a judge and after he
shoots him he shoves his judgment wrong
that's very frustrated Irsay Nathaniel
Richmond and the judge who was armed
fired their weapons about five times
each a probation officer near the judge
also shot Richmond there wasn't a
probation officer this gentleman would
kept on shooting till he killed the
judge Richmond son Malik was convicted
in a high-profile rape case in 2013 he
felt
he hadn't done anything wrong Malik
Richmond and another Steubenville high
school football player were accused of
sexually assaulting an unconscious 16
year old girl at a party in 2012 judge
brizzy's oversaw the grand jury in the
case but stepped aside because he said
he thought it was necessary to appoint a
judge from outside of Steubenville
prosecutor Jayne Hanlon says they are
still looking for a motive in the
shooting
absolutely no reason to believe records
show Judge brizzy's was also overseeing
a wrongful death suit filed by the
alleged gunman against the Jefferson
County Metropolitan Housing Authority
the suit was on behalf of his mother's
estate after she died in a fire in April
a hearing was scheduled for August 28th
it's too early for us to tell whether
there is any connection between that
lawsuit in the incident that happened
this morning now judge brizzy's did
undergo emergency surgery he is expected
to survive
police say there was another man in the
car with Richmond when he arrived here
that man is now being questioned by
police Margaret Yurika thank you